asl
[Musik]
ein zauberer und eine lampe die mehr
kann als leuchten an dieser zauber
nummer hat patrick lehnen gute vier
jahre lang gearbeitet
am bühnenbild musik und dramaturgie die
leute wirklich berührt und etwas auslöst
in einem dass man halt nicht nur guckt
und denkt auch das war ja verblüffende
zauberei saßen ein wirklich berührt und
bewegt und wahre emotionen schafft und
dass ihm gelungen denn die freche zauber
lampe steht man sofort intern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wenn patrick lehnen nicht auf der bühne
steht arbeitet der 34 jährige kölner
hauptberuflich als programmierer seine
zauber lampe hat er selbst gebaut und
verkabelt ein mühseliger akt das paar so
ist die verkabelung quasi intern ganz
schön kompliziert drei jahre an dieser
nummer gebastelt sie sich das erste mal
zeigen konnte und dann war sich an dem
theater und die spielte diese nummer und
wusste einfach gar nicht wie kommt das
jetzt also mögen die leute da ist oder
nicht ist das nur mein kopf voll oder
oder aber nicht um
zum schluss gab's eine standing ovation
und lustig klar dass simulieren hat ihm
geholfen zaubern zu lernen denn auch
dabei geht es in erster linie um
fingerfertigkeit
vor elf jahren war er karten kunststücke
im internet und begann sie nach zu
machen bis er alle griffe braucht hatte
[Musik]
dann war irgendwie der funke
übergesprungen und ich habe versucht
alles zu lernen was ich finden konnte an
kartentricks und aber nicht wirklich
nicht so in der intention dass
vorzuführen sondern ehre für mich so
einfach so als hätten müssen rumspielen
auf der suche nach neuen kartentricks
besuchte er zauber waren händler und
lernte dabei andere magier und weitere
zauberkunststücke kennen
kein problem dann machen wir's einfach
war wie immer bevor die erste
anlaufstelle wie die kollegen
kennengelernt habe wird vermag ich die
türkei erfahren habe bekam ich ja die
gelegenheit war auch mitglied bewertung
zwischen sind ja sogar in bonn im
vorstand dabei der pferd organisiert er
mit anderen mitgliedern des magischen
zirkels die bonner zauber wochen zu
sehen sind die besten zauberkünstler des
landes aus ganz unterschiedlichen
sparten wie der bayer samuel goldmann
aus dem bereich der manipulation fünf
jahre gearbeitet und auch durchaus
normal weiß einfach jahre dauert bis man
überhaupt die basics erlernt hat also
die griffe zum beispiel hier so was ein
ganz typischer cash für manipulatoren
[Musik]
großillusionen hingegen sind nur im team
zu bewältigen und benötigen viel platz
mit ihrem selbst gebauten zauber
maschinen sind flick flack mord an magic
aus landau in der pfalz zweimal
deutscher meister geworden
bei den kollisionen ist timing ist sehr
wichtig dass alles genau auf die musik
passt jeder weiß wann er was zu tun hat
also timing ist da das wichtigste von
allem das ist sehr schwierig das muss
man lange üben immer wieder immer wieder
das gleiche durchführen proben üben wird
es richtig passt der klassiker der große
illusion ist die zersägte jungfrau in
immer neuen variationen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
so viele unfassbar gute zauber nummern
und wir haben jetzt nicht das element
was was sie besonders macht dennoch
irgendwie was spezielles manchmal ist
der charakter der unfassbar fasziniert
ist dass man die ganze zeit zuschauen
möchte manchmal ist es ein spezieller
effekt der so verblüffend ist dass man
es immer wieder gucken möchte oder
manchmal einfach die story so mitreißend
wie bei seiner zauber lampe mit ihr hat
patrick lehnen eine ganz eigene frau
magischer poesie erschaffen
ein highlight in der geheimnisvollen
welt der magie
[Applaus]
[Musik]